en 1999 après des études de droit
je décide d'ouvrir une école d'art
peut-être par souvenirs de mon enfance
où j'ai eu la chance de pratiquer
différentes activités artistiques
nous voulons retrouver un peu cette
nostalgie du passé donc enthousiasmé par
cette idée de nous trouvions génial
d'ouvrir une école d'art
nous décidons d'en parler à notre
entourage je me rappelle qu'à cette
période je faisais une formation en
informatique une courte formation
d'initiation à l'informatique et notre
professeur qui était très agréable très
sympathique jeu on décide de lui en
parler en fait et donc de lui soumettre
cette idée est là en bon ingénieur
informaticien pragmatique cartésien il
me regarde et me dit vous allez ouvrir
une école d'art ça voudrait dire que
hannah england comme nicklas trois
étages une seule machine des cours de
guitare alors ça enlever un peu de
poésie atouts de cette belle initiative
d'autres personnes nous ont dit mais les
algériens impossible ils sont concentrés
sur leur tube digestif ouvre un petit
restaurant hamburger cheese pizzeria ça
marchera mais l'art c'est pas pour eux
nous décidons quand même de nous lancer
dans cette initiative est donc forcément
nous entamons des certaines procédures
administratives il nous arrivait donc
parfois d'aller voir des agents pour
régler des problèmes comme tout le monde
je suppose peuvent connaître et donc
arrivons avec notre document de notre
établissement ne viser et kolda
dayraut la danse donc vous pouvez
imaginer il ya quelques années ce que
pouvait faire 7 heures ce type de
réaction passe à notre naïve volonté
d'ouvrir une simple école d'art
quinze ans après nous avons confirmé il
n'était pas inscrit dans les gènes des
algériens qui ne peut s'atteindre est-ce
qu'il ne s'intéresserait pas à l'art et
nous avons ainsi formé des centaines
d'enfants et d'adultes à différentes
disciplines artistiques
je m'appelle donc à fira voir ci-bas bas
et je suis la fondatrice de l'école
artissimo au départ j'avais l'intention
de lancer cette cette école et puis de
la superviser de loin sauf que c'était
sans prendre conscience rapidement à l'
aventure humaine qui s'est offerte à moi
rapidement rencontrer des artistes même
près nier de leur état d'esprit de leur
passion répondre aux attentes des
personnes qui venaient nous voir tout
cela m'a fait très vite réalisé que je
co final je ne travaillerai pas dans un
autre secteur que celui de la culture et
que bien sûr je n'oublierai jamais mon
cabinet d'avocats t que je n'aurai
jamais de métier sérieux comme on dit
bien entendu tout n'a pas été très rose
dès le départ il ya eu certaines
incompréhensions par moments d'une part
pas parmi les personnes qui venaient
nous voir et qui s'intéressait à ses
activités
certains ne prenez pas forcément
conscience de la rigueur que cela
implique et on pouvait par moment
considéré que pratiquer une activité
artistique
c'était de l'ordre du divertissement et
que du coup telle une baguette magique
nous allions faire
des pianistes de grande envergure des
grands artistes peintres malheureusement
ce n'était pas le cas de notre côté nous
avons eu aussi certaines difficultés
par moments dans notre méthode
d'apprentissage d'enlever pédagogie que
nous utilisions nous de nous nous avons
peut-être favorisé un peu plus l'aspect
technique et académique de cet
apprentissage
ce qui par moments nous a fait perdre le
sens de ce que nous voulions faire c'est
à dire transmettre cette passion aux
enfants et aux adultes qui venaient nous
voir
j'ai moi même été un jeune eu des
professeurs très sévère qui m'ont fait
fuir ses activités notamment le piano
que j'ai eu à la la la la la la chance
de pratiquer quelques fois faim pendant
une partie de mon enfance mais j'ai
aussi rencontré d'autres personnes
d'autres professeurs qui m'ont emporté
et transmis cette passion il y avait
aussi alors ça c'est un peu un petit peu
tabou par moments on a eu là on a pu
constater tout au long de cette année
que maintenant c'est de ses 15 ans
pardon que le l'apprentissage ou l'accès
à la culture était liée à la langue vous
allez vous demander pourquoi très
souvent dans malheureusement beaucoup de
situations nous avons vu que des gens
considérés que aller voir un concert de
musique ou venir s'inscrire à une
activité artistique était lié au fait
que nous parlions le français et que
quelqu'un qui n'était pas forcément
francophones étaient algériens comme une
voilà qui parlaient l'arabe et bien
quelque part ses portes pouvait lui être
fermé et qu'ils interdisaient de devenir
ne serait-ce que nous voir pour des
renseignements
parce que ça avait cette connotation un
peu francophone du coup il a fallu
malgré tout en vain de du mieux que l'on
a dû combattre un peu tous et toutes ces
petites difficultés qu'ils font partie
de notre qui ont fait partie de notre
parcours
il ya aussi cette notion de doué ou pas
doué on vient me dire mais je voudrais
jours
de chanter et pourtant je ma voix est
catastrophique
alors si je peux vous rassurer
effectivement il peut y avoir peut-être
en pourcentage juste maximum 2% à 3% de
personnes qui ont des prédispositions
mais tout le reste les 98% sont
véritablement travail et rigueur
alors du coup on se dit mais à quoi ça
sert au final ça a été notre première
mission
notre mission n'a pas été de forcément
de former des artistes de grande
envergure
bien que certains de nos élèves ans ont
choisi d'en faire une carrière
mais notre mission première ça a été de
faire ressortir cette sensibilité
naturelle qui est en nous et qui est en
chacun de se dire que ce jeune enfant ou
adulte qui vient nous voir aujourd'hui
pour apprendre un instrument ou
apprendre à destiner offert une
formation en graphisme en décoration
d'intérieur demain pourra aller visiter
un musée pour aller assister à un
concert de musique pourra s'émerveiller
devant une simple une peinture ou pourra
apprécier un moment d'introspection en
écoutant un joli morceau de musique et
c'est ça qui a été notre vision et notre
objectif le plus important et du coup on
se dit que finalement à quoi ça sert cet
art-là cet art pour ma part peut-être
considérer quand même témoignage de tout
ce qui fait ressortir la sensibilité ou
les aspirations les plus belles et plus
profonde de l'homme
ça peut être aussi un emblème quand je
dis emblème je parle de peut-être de
référence identitaire
récemment j'ai passé quelques jours en
espagne à barcelone plus
particulièrement et j'ai été frappée dès
mon arrivée à l'aéroport par tous les
visuels les supports publicitaires qui
se présentaient à
faisant référence à garou dit faisant
référence à picasso faisant référence à
salvatore dali partout où j'allais dans
les restaurants les lélés les cafés les
magasins du doping et ben ont trouvé des
éléments visuels qui faisait ressortir
et qui mettait en valeur ces artistes là
je me suis donc demandé que peut-être
ces espagnols étaient suffisamment fier
de cette de ce patrimoine artistique
pour vouloir le partager avec nous nous
touristes avec le monde entier et cela
en dehors des parcours touristiques
qu'ils en étaient suffisamment fier pour
le mettre suffisamment lumière peut-être
même plus que le barça qui est toutes
les équipes espagnoles qui sont
mondialement connus ça m'a un peu
questionné sur ma position en tant
qu'algérienne et du coup je me suis
rappelé qu'il ya quelques mois j'avais
visionné une vidéo un codex d'ailleurs
par hasard qui avait été présenté par là
j'ai ramé ya ça qui est la soeur de
l'émir du qatar et qui est très active
dans le domaine de l'action culturelle
et dans son taux de qu'elle présentait à
washington un moment elle cite l'artiste
peintre bahia intéressant donc ma fierté
a su mon ego algérien me dit c'est quand
même je m'en suis senti très fier en
fait que l'on puisse en parler avec
beaucoup d'éloges et parler de son
parcours à des personnes qui n'avaient
peut-être jamais entendu parler de
l'algérie qui elle en tant que voix la
personne on va dire public venant du
bout du monde
la sitcom référence m'a quand même donné
une certaine une certaine fierté voilà
je me répète un peu et du coup je me dis
que nous en tant qu'algérien est-ce que
nous sommes suffisamment conscients de
notre patrimoine
est-ce que nous sommes suffisamment
informés
notre production artistique de notre
richesse artistique et seulement
suffisamment informés pour se
l'approprier en tant qu'identité devons
nous être connu en algérie par notre
équipe de football ou par le pétrole et
le gaz que nous avons certes c'est une
bonne chose mais peut-être que nous
serions encore plus riche de notre
identité en valorisant nos artistes et
notre richesse artistique et pas
seulement pour nous parce que bien sûr
que c'est important mais ça peut être
aussi c'est tout aussi important pour
justement s'ouvrir aux pulls tueur d
autres s'ouvrir aux cultures dans toute
leur diversité
s'ouvrir à l'étranger à ce qui vient
d'ailleurs les accueillir et aussi se
l'approprier cela à mon sens peut nous
grandir un peu plus je parlais tout à
l'heure de référence identitaire au
d'emblème je peux citer bien entendu
comme l'a fait bien les à léonard de
vinci qui bien entendu a été d'un grand
artiste mais qui aussi a été un immense
homme de science et que si l'on relit
son parcours toutes les filiales
beaucoup de fluidité entre c'est ce sont
ces domaines de recherche et l'influencé
qu'il a eue qu'a eu l'art sur sa sur son
développement personnel
un autre exemple que tout le monde
connaît steve jobs ce qui malgré tout la
révolution technologique qui là qu'il a
apporté au 20e siècle mais il n'empêche
que si ces produits n'avait pas eu le
design qu'ils avaient l'ergonomie le tac
du touch tactile
les couleurs utilisées qui donc ils qui
ont fait appel à des créatifs ils
n'auraient pas eu peut-être tout ce
succès et du coup on peut se dire que
vous l futurs ingénieurs ou en tout cas
ingénieurs déjà pour certains d'entre
vous il ne il ne pourrait pas être et
n'est pas forcément étonnant pour vous
d'un jour travaillé dans le milieu de ce
que l'on peut appeler les industries
culturelles
imaginez maintenant qu'il est il est
impensable d'aller assister à
un spectacle de théâtre sans avoir les
effets lumineux de dernière technologie
sans avoir les vidéo dernier cri
on ne peut pas imaginer voir un cinéma
de science fiction sans avoir les
derniers effets spéciaux et donc tout ça
c'est un espère un mélange entre la
technologie et les métiers créatifs
d'ailleurs les industries culturelles
dans beaucoup de pays ont un impact
économique très important certains pays
ont des le chiffre d'affaires en termes
économique des industries culturelles
peut dépasser le pib de d'autres pays
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
est porteur de richesses et qui en plus
permet cette fluidité comme ça se
passait dans le siècle précédent au
siècle précédent
c'était de mixer la technologie est là
les gars bien entendu et et on voit
d'ailleurs qu'aujourd'hui les choses ont
changé c'est à dire que si on reprend
notre contexte algérien on n'accepte
plus de vivre disons n'acceptent plus
cette vie d'artiste ou d'être un
ingénieur et d'avoir un métier sérieux
et en même temps pratiqué ou travailler
dans un domaine culturel
rappelez vous lorsque je vous parlais de
notre fameux agent qui me parlait de la
de la danse et bien maintenant lorsque
je me rends dans certaines
administrations on nous dit pu artissimo
béraud la danse mais on me dit vous avez
une école d'art j'aimerais m'y inscrire
mon fils ma fille mon neveu ma nièce
donc ça veut dire que les choses
changent que les mentalités changent et
ça je trouve que c'est très positif
il ne faudrait cependant pas s'arrêter
là pour permettre l'éducation et l'accès
à la culture à tout le monde et à tous
les niveaux
il faudrait la démocratiser il faudrait
l'ouvrir aux autres il faudrait
s'approprier les espaces publics
il faudrait faire accéder l'éducation à
tout le monde et il faudrait sûr
ou du moins aussi valoriser et
promouvoir les artistes algériens qu'il
soit ici ou ailleurs et se les
approprier bien entendu pour s'enrichir
ou enrichir notre humanité
je finirai par cette citation n'étant
pas très doué pour technologie donc je
dirais voilà seul l'art et la science
élève l'homme jusqu'à la divinité
donc je suggère de prendre un peu de
hauteur et je vous remercie